this week on ryan ross investigates
dark days and the scariest halloween
ever a second and third wave of coven 19
rolling through the country just like
1918
historians tell us we have failed to
learn from the past
we see lots of pushback both at the
personal level as well as the political
level
that we saw in 1918 the big difference
is that that pushback is now highly
politicized that was not the case in
1918
plus the apostles handmaid one of the
women alleged to have groomed and
recruited young girls to perform sex
acts for the leader of a huge
international church has now pleaded
guilty in california court
we'll get the inside story from someone
who was there
they do it because they think it's the
right thing to do and
and you're pleasing him and it's a
blessing
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with what the editors
of mediaite have to say
about the tv anchor who likened the
president to a crazy uncle
that was a retweet i'll put it out there
people can decide for themselves
you're not like someone's crazy uncle
who can just reach me whatever
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always tonight
by rhonda schwartz in the law and crime
network
and rhonda we begin with a major
development in a story we've been
following closely for more than a year
new charges involving the apostle a man
by the name of
nathan joaquin garcia and one of his
handmaiden
he's accused of recruiting and running a
huge sex trafficking ring
involving young girls from his own
church in southern california rhonda
that's right brian alondra ocampo is one
of his inner
circle a sort of handmaiden accused of
helping him recruit teenagers for sex
in a major development she has pled
guilty to four felony counts related to
child sex abuse
and we're told she will likely testify
against him in his upcoming trial
it's a potentially huge setback for his
upcoming criminal
defense
prosecutors say the apostle for all his
religious glory
has always had women in the church who
helped to recruit and groom young girls
in their teens
for him to abuse and rape prosecutors
say olandra ocampo was one of them
she was arrested with garcia last year
and agents have testified extensively
how young victims described ocampo's
role as one of the apostles
handmaidens ocampo requested that jane
doe number one
send her nude photos of herself
because the servant of god who is
defendant garcia
would be really happy if they sent
pictures not wearing
any clothes or something similar to that
agents testified that the young girls
were recruited from the light of the
world churches
in the southern california area
including this one in east los angeles
always invoking the apostles status as
jesus on earth
to get the girls to submit to his sexual
whims
did jane do one tell you whether
defendant ocampo
suggested that jane doe one did not love
god
or the apostle if she did not comply
with that request
that is correct agents testified that
our capital would take the young girls
to victoria's secret stores to buy
scanty lingerie for them to wear
as she filmed them for the apostle she
was provided by miss o'connell um
provided
whipped cream strawberries lingerie
and the other girl that would spray the
whipped cream
and and strawberries on each other and
lift them off and
she said that mr campbell told her that
the photos were for mr garcia
and that she would send them to him to
get a better understanding of the import
of all this we're joined now by social
martin
and her lawyer deborah malgrave social
you were once in the orbit of the
apostle and you understand fully what
ms ocampa has been through yes i do
and can you understand how she would be
able to recruit other young girls
i do i do because i believe she was
brainwashed
i do believe that
i believe all the girls were because i
was
i lived it nobody told me nobody said
hey i think this is happening or i have
a picture to show you
i i lived it my entire life i lived it
so it's not a he said she said given her
plea what what does that tell you about
what she did for the apostle
the gravity of
the harm that she committed against
these girls
are not something that she
woke up one day and said that that's
something she wanted me to do and this
is this was all
nathan's doing um
and i'm happy i'm happy she came forward
i'm happy she's
she you know the truth shall set you
free
and from your experience garcia recruits
women like this to recruit other women
for him
that's what he asked you to do exactly
let me ask your lawyer deborah magrave
what do you think is the impact of this
on the case against
uh mason garcia well i i think
uh it's definitely a a good sign
and incredibly helpful and i think the
guilty plea in her statements
uh just go to show that one of the
co-conspira
conspirators of nathan garcia believes
that there's strong enough evidence out
there
to convince people beyond a reasonable
doubt of the charges that have been
alleged against them um and and i
believe that significance can in
not be lost upon defendants or others
that are out there
who have been conspiring with
mason garcia for these crimes as you
know garcia's lawyers pointed a finger
at your client social martin when she
first came forward
uh claiming in court papers that she was
as responsible
as he was i assume they'll try to do the
same thing with uh
ocampo in in
i assume so as well and i think all that
just goes to show you that
uh how hard it is to resist
being in nathan garcia's orbit
in terms of his grooming his
manipulation his coercion
on his part and others to silence those
around him
and to convince them um and enforce them
into helping with his own um agenda and
that of others uh in the organization
committing crimes
and social martial let me ask you for
many people it's hard to understand why
young people would go along with this
why do they
they go along with it because they think
it's a blessing
they don't they don't doubt that the
servant of god is lying to them
or that he's committing a crime against
them
you that's the last thing in your mind
you're not even allowed
your mind's not allowed to go there so
they do it because they think it's the
right thing to do and
and you're pleasing him and it's a
blessing you're
he would tell us you you're you're
you're making
you have a crown in the sky
and in that crown that social has or
you know alondra has or any other
of these women even the jane does any
crown
that you have in the sky every time you
do something for me
you have a little pearl or a diamond
that you're working for to get that
pearl or diamond
uh or that precious gem on that crown
so you're working for those blessings
for the
afterlife and someday hope that you know
all
everything that you did here on earth
you know god will
will repay you one day in heaven
and how do you feel now that the wheels
of justice are continuing to turn
towards
a trial for the apostle
i'm happy because i think that we can
just expect
good news and we can expect this to keep
moving forward and
and the truth is is there and
justice is there and
and i think that there's just so much
evil and there's so much harm that's
been done for so many years
that i think that it was time
it was time social martin
and deborah magrave thank you both for
joining us this evening and continuing
to give us
insights into this strange world of the
impossible
thank you brian thank you brian
a spokesman for the light of the world
church continues to insist the apostle
is
innocent of all the charges against him
up next
could this be the scariest halloween
ever
when we come back lessons learned and
not learned from 1918.
you're watching the law and crime trial
network
we're joined now by dr j alex navarro
from the center for the history of
medicine at the university of michigan
and alex thank you so much for joining
us
as they say uh kova 19 will be uglier
the second time around
that's what they're saying i think uh
many of us
could have predicted this unfortunately
and
it was the case in in 1918 to some
extent in a lot of cities that
issued closure orders and types the
types of gathering bans that we saw
earlier in the spring and early summer
when they lifted them people went back
to life as normal
and in a great many cities that second
spike of cases was just as bad if not
worse than the first
first go-around we're about to have two
major events
in this country the elections and
halloween
how were those handled in 1918
um generally i have to talk about the
different regions and they were handled
differently depending on where in the
country
you were in 1918 in the northeast the
epidemic was over quicker because a lot
of people got sick
very quickly they had short and steep um
epidemic curves and so for them
halloween generally went on
as usual and the election was handled
as usual for cities in places of the
midwest and the west it was a little bit
different if you had public gathering
bans many of those cities admonish their
citizens there
to not let the kids go out uh for
halloween and keep in mind halloween in
1918 was drastically different than it
is today it wasn't really about
trick-or-treating it was more about the
tricks
uh kids went out usually young boys went
out and caused a great deal of vandalism
and you had
lots of police officers telling kids you
know don't go out and destroy things
uh because we have a lot of people who
are who are convalescing from
from illness and can't go and repair the
damage
in terms of the elections places for
example in california
had a shortage of poll workers either
due directly to illness or people who
were scared of working at the polls and
so they had to
sometimes at the very last minute uh
recruit people to work the polls
uh places in utah for example held uh
elections in outdoor tents so they
create polling places outdoors they
realize that that was a little bit
safer there were people who there were
rumors in
north dakota for example that the um
election might be postponed and
officials had to say no no in fact the
election is is going on as usual
so based on the history of what happened
what do you think is the best
course of action for this halloween this
election
well i think we need to listen to public
health officials who are telling us that
you know
gatherings and as we see now a great
number of states are seeing an increase
a dramatic increase in case counts you
know even
small gatherings are problematic and
certainly uh so having halloween parties
i think is is really out of the question
and i think even going door-to-door
um although there might be ways to do
that that could be relatively safe i
think it's a it's a risk factor you know
i i would
admonish people to listen to public
health officers and to to
really maybe cancel the traditional
halloween uh that we usually see
and as for the election it's not going
to be canceled lots of people are now
voting early to avoid the
crush on election day yeah you know i
think
in general though there have been some
issues in various states you know states
have realized that
uh the gathering for election day in the
midst of the pandemic is is not good and
so they've expanded the options for
absentee voting or early voting uh you
know we have seen some crowds formed in
in some states that have opened up early
voting
uh but at least from what i've seen
people are wearing masks and they're
trying to maintain a social distance
and they're outdoors so i think so far
uh it seems to be pretty safe i'm not an
epidemiologist but
i'm hard to to see what i have been
seeing
the research shows that in 1918 this
three months of autumn were really
perhaps the cruelest months
can we expect the same thing here now
you know it's possible and certainly
that's what some public health officials
have been warning us about
you know influenza is a different virus
than coronavirus and so it behaves a
little bit differently
uh and and so the timing may not be be
exact but
you know we have seen that indoor
gatherings are hugely problematic and as
people as the weather starts to cool off
as we
head into the fall into the winter the
great fear is that people are going to
return to gathering indoors as opposed
to
outdoors and we know that that is a much
higher risk factor for spreading uh
in covet and so yes i do think we
are in for a pretty bad fall
and we see so many parallels between the
pandemic this year and what happened in
1918
almost more than 100 years ago with the
early outbreak
in spring and then a sense over the
summer maybe we're past it
and now again we're facing a resurgence
it's a kind of a
w uh recovery right down up
down up yeah and in some ways i think
you can
you know we're we're really experiencing
now nationally a third a third peak
of a third surge of cases we've never
really got a good handle on
the national case counts to begin with
and what we've seen
is that it just shifted to different
different regions of the country it
started
you know with new york for example being
a major hot spot in the metropolitan
area in new jersey
in michigan and then now it's it's
moving into other places you know the
south was hit and now
into the upper midwest uh we're really
playing whack-a-mole with
with where this coronavirus is is um
causing outbreaks i think we need to get
a national handle
uh on it in 1918 were there major
national
public figures uh like president trump
has done this time
that have sort of uh cast dispersions on
the seriousness of this and
suggesting everyone recovers it's going
to disappear
uh yes and no not at the national level
um you know this in 1918 it was before
the cdc was created for example in 1946
and the federal response was really
quite limited to mostly the military
camps where there was an early outbreak
pretty much across the nation of course
this was a time of world war one and
troop mobilization
uh at the local level there were a great
number of local health officers who at
least initially
said um you know influenza is going to
be a problem it will come in and it will
blow
in and out pretty quickly that's at
least what they thought initially based
on their previous experience with
influenza epidemics including one in
1889 1890
they realized within usually a matter of
a week or so
as the case counts skyrocketed and then
deaths
followed immediately after that this was
an entirely different beast they were
dealing with and that's when they
started to tell people you need to take
this seriously you need to avoid crowds
they implemented school closures and
gathering bands and some business
closures is it troubling to you as a
historian and somebody who knows about
medicine that we really haven't learned
many lessons from 1918
it's very troubling uh especially when
now you know
post new deal we have a sense
that the federal government needs to
take a stronger role in
in national crises and we haven't really
seen that
we see that just like in 1918 lots of
people want to get back to normal life
before
it's it's safe to do so we see lots of
pushback both at the personal level as
well as the political level
uh that we saw in 1918 the big
difference is that that pushback is now
highly politicized that was not the case
in 1918 so in some ways i think
not only have we not learned the lessons
of 1918 we've done a worse job
considering that we should be much
better prepared to handle
a big pandemic like the kova 19 one
j alex navarro from the center for the
history of medicine at the university of
michigan
thank you so much again for joining us
this evening you're welcome thank you
for having me
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin
editor-in-chief of media which like the
law and crime trial network
is part of the dan abrams media empire
and in your first win of this week
savannah guthrie of nbc news
who went toe-to-toe in a town hall last
week with president trump
this week you retweeted to your 87
million followers a conspiracy theory
that joe biden orchestrated to have seal
team six the navy seal two six killed to
cover up
the the fake death of bin laden now why
would you send a line like that to your
followers
that was a retweet that was a an opinion
of somebody
and that was a retweet i'll put it out
there people can decide for themselves
you're not like someone's crazy uncle
who can just reach me whatever that was
a retweet
she did a great job aidan not someone's
crazy uncle right
yeah so there was a huge amount of
pressure as you know on savannah guthrie
last week to really put on a good show
and
actually interview trump in a way that
was successful uh because
there was so much uh criticism of nbc
for scheduling their town hall
with trump at the same time as abc was
having a town hall with joe biden
after trump had pulled out of the
virtual second debate so
there was an enormous amount of
criticism of nbc there was a lot of
pressure on savannah guthrie to do a
good job as moderator of this town hall
and i think she did a really spectacular
job she questioned trump
on things that were you know that are
serious questions for the president
his supporters were sort of angry at the
questions that she asked
um they thought they were too harsh i
think if the president is retweeting
conspiracy theories that bin laden
wasn't actually killed
uh by a navy seal raid and that there
was a sort of conspiracy theory at the
top
levels of government that joe biden and
barack obama
sort of killed a body double that's
something that a moderator should ask a
president about
um she also asked him about q anon uh
this sort of
crazy conspiracy theory that uh there's
a sort of satanic cult that trump is
fighting back against that's comprised
of top democrats um that's again is
something that the president should be
asked about
uh and she did a really good job of
asking these questions following up
she did something that i've noticed a
lot of other interviewers that have been
successful
in questioning the president have done
which is treating
the crazy stuff that the president says
as crazy jonathan swann of axios is
really good at that so is chris wallace
of fox news
to a certain extent i think you can't
really question the president like you
would any other politician
because there's a lot of stuff that he
says that's really nuts
and you have to at a certain point treat
it as nuts like she did when she said
you know you're not america's crazy
uncle
and i think that one phrase really kind
of put together the whole thing we got
it
this week's uh media loser uh one of the
white house's top
medical advisors dr scott atlas
yeah so dr fauci dr anthony fauci is
probably the most well known
uh coronavirus task force member who's
advising the president on the pandemic
i would say the most influential uh is
certainly not dr fauci because the
president is currently having a kind of
a public
uh spat with him uh it's this other uh
doctor named scott atlas
uh who is not an infectious disease
expert he's actually a radiologist
um but he appeared on fox news a lot and
questioned a lot of what the
administration scientists were saying
about lockdowns and masks
trump really liked him so he invited him
to serve as an advisor on the
coronavirus task force
now he's had a really rough week there
was a report out in the watch
today that uh that deborah burks who's
another member of the chronovirus task
force
asked mike pence to get rid of scott
atlas because she believes that he's
feeding bad information to president
donald trump
he was on twitter questioning saying
that maps don't work
which flies in the face of the
administration's own guidelines the
cdc's own guidelines
um so he's really an outlier on the task
force a lot of infectious disease
experts who disagree vehemently with all
of his
policy prescription and he's advising
the president so it's a really
it's a problem for the chronovirus task
force that this person is on it
and i think it's going to continue to
sort of make sure that the american
response to the crisis
is completely inconsistent
absolutely well aidan mclaughlin thank
you so much once again for this week's
winners and losers in the media as
always and thanks to all of you for
watching and
thanks to our great team at long crime
for getting us on the air
and for getting us off the air
successfully
[Music]
you